Conor McGregor just tweeted at me
because of this interview she has to get
active again you know who knows when
that's gonna happen these are his tweets
and here's my response Connor Connor
Connor you're more active on Twitter
than you are in the Octagon stop taking
tremb alone and start taking fights
you're more actively cheating on your
way than you are in the Octagon your
priorities are mixed up put down the
bottle and get back of fighting you
haven't won a fight in five [ __ ]
years and the last time you did was
against cowboy Cerrone who hasn't won a
fight against anyone since fighting you
I'm a nobody you say in this tweet well
yeah you're right I'm just a [ __ ] kid
from Ohio I really am a nobody but this
is where you fought your sixth fight
there's literally two people in the
crowd and this is where I'm gonna be
fighting my sixth fight Madison Square
Garden the mecca of boxing August 6th I
know you'll be watching kiddo here's
another fun fact in your 18th fight you
made a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in my fifth fight I made 15
million you want to talk about
pay-per-view buys Nate Robinson 1.8
million Ben Astron 500
Tyrone Woodley two no one even wanted to
see that fight and we got 200 000
pay-per-view Buys in the last five years
you've had zero pay-per-view buys
because you don't [ __ ] fight you have
a lot to say about me but I'm sharing
millions of dollars with underpaid
Fighters while you're sharing hookers
with Dana White
no wait for it wild [ __ ] boys
yeah oops I'm sorry God
you shouldn't have [ __ ] with me Connor
this is my game there's a new King in
town I'm running [ __ ] now what's up
Connor what's up what's up last year
when I won knockout of the year you were
just getting knocked out fix your
Calcium deficiency stop breaking your
bones and let's get in the [ __ ] ring
and make 200 million dollars I don't
know no matter how you slice it we're
just not on the same level I'm My Own
Boss yeah you made 100 million dollars
when you fought Floyd but Dana took half
of it so no matter what you do or what
you make cut that [ __ ] in half we went
net worth for net worth I would [ __ ] on
you Connor with the bottle down get off
of Twitter get back in the ring and shut
the [ __ ] up I'm gonna put you back on a
leash [ __ ] you Connor
yeah they talk good [ __ ] though it's
almost like it's all good [ __ ]
if you're just an average like
run-of-the-mill fighter yeah
would you fight Jake
knowing what you and your family is
gonna have to go through you I think you
would because it's a Payday yeah fair
enough that's right but you really got
to look at that number and go is this
[ __ ] worth it like you got to sit
down with your family because like you
said babies coming after you he's coming
after everything he's gonna get videos
from my pet it is he's gonna make you
earn that [ __ ] money boy you're
already risking their life going in the
ring it's like but it's different like a
family son imagine you're a girl he's
posting pictures and [ __ ] yeah you know
what I mean like pictures of Eugene now
your girl gotta talk to her friends
about it she going to the store she's
gonna go upstairs publicly she's
embarrassed nah that [ __ ] is crazy and
here's what you brought up this is he's
not even fighting Conor yet this is
pre-fight hype [ __ ] and I'll be honest
who wants the fight is announced
man so if he fights Conor in boxing he's
[ __ ] common I think that's I think
he's gonna win I think so the only thing
I don't get why are you doing this
before the fight he's it makes it seem
like you're not even like interested in
this fight like it's not gonna be a good
fight I think it's more just like
anything
to promote him because he's gonna have
to promote everything for this fight oh
okay because a lot of people don't know
I've seen Rockman yeah Junior right so
it's like it's all gonna have to be
interesting Jake and maybe
maybe what he can do is get the boxing
Community to be like finally the here's
a real boxer all the boxing fans are
gonna hate on Jake and then all the
boxing fans are gonna buy the fight so
that they can watch and take potentially
lose in the same way like Floyd made all
that money it was a lot of [ __ ]
just paying to see him finally get
beaten up yeah I think that's the angle
for this Oh no I got to see him but
if you're a fighter do you want to bark
up that tree
you gotta do like an audit you got to
get a company to like go through your
whole history like on some presidential
[ __ ] wipe everything clean yeah get all
your family member get all this [ __ ] off
yeah because anything I assume he hasn't
already gone through it because even
this again fight's not announced fight
isn't on the table and he's already
going through your [ __ ] yeah well I'm
sure people will send him stuff yeah
that's the other thing yeah once you
show that you're doing this type of
content or you're exposing people like
this people who like to expose are going
to be out there yo have you seen this
video theoretically that girl not that
she did but she could have just taken
the video sent it right to him
I'm not saying that that happened I'm
saying that's a that's now that he like
you know he'll do that and you could do
that a girl could do that get some dirt
send it right away I'm not sending to
anybody I'll just [ __ ] this guy or this
will help you out and maybe get me a
favor with you whatever so let's say
that this is something I'm interested
with that girl it's like these girls are
prostitutes right
and this is you know you get paid to
leave you don't get paid for the sex you
get paid to leave you heard that yeah
best quote ever so
greatest quote ever Charlie Sheen hero
oh did he say that yeah oh okay so
I'm wondering
if this affects her bottom dollar you're
the type of girl that gets paid by very
rich dudes to [ __ ] now you've shown that
you can't be trusted correct you have
incriminating evidence who's [ __ ]
that girl now and the service that you
might have used to get this girl because
you're not just getting her up the
street at this level of wealth you got a
call to madam or something like yo bring
it through that's huge violation like
you get fired like that girl's done
right yeah there's gonna be some people
that look at that and they go oh good
enough for Connor good enough for me 100
that's that rapper [ __ ] yeah 100 but is
it worth the risk like now if if you're
[ __ ] with these girls you literally
unless you have some wild Kink that they
can satisfy if you're just trying to get
some [ __ ] on the side while you're in
some Dubai or whatever the [ __ ] it is is
it worth your family to be with the
[ __ ] that videotape [ __ ] and then but
most guys don't have a giant social
digital footprint that you know like if
some girl posts something from hooking
up with like some Finance guy and stuff
oh whatever like it's not gonna
necessarily pop up this guy there's a
level unless she targets them I I hear I
hear what he's saying I guess I'm I'm
all I'm wondering like did she [ __ ] up
her own prospects in this career yes 100
and like um [ __ ] what is the word that
I'm looking for like it's not security
but a discretion discretion is part of
the job it is incredibly important and
you're paying a premium for it it's like
I don't let's say she's a ten thousand
dollar a night girl
hey ain't no difference in [ __ ] between
one thousand and ten I'm not paying you
for your attractiveness I'm paying you
for sure that's another thing like throw
a filter on shorty like this is you like
I'm assuming she posts this on like her
Instagram close friends or whatever and
then someone else rips it and like she
accidentally leaks it yeah but it still
[ __ ] your career also the dudes if you
see this as your career they might not
see this as a career this might be like
a play to get more attention or whatever
yeah that's the thing go go to Mark's
point like I think there's a lot of
dudes that see that as like oh [ __ ] she
was with Connor like Oh I wanna I wanna
get agreed 100 rap is good I should all
the time all players dude I should all
you think Stormy Daniels like career is
better or worse since she like snitched
on Trump that's true I think it's worse
I saw her stripping in a club like uh
yeah but what was she doing before Trump
yeah what do you mean that's an upgrade
I don't no longer have to [ __ ] guys I
can just dance and people are coming
just to see me because and you went just
to go see her I remember that I did yeah
that's a bad dudes in the front row
would make America great again hats
good enough for Trump good enough for me
that's probably what those dudes are
thinking that's a great point
I guess the ideal scenario would be
if someone else leaks a video that's not
from your phone like the both of you are
seen going into the hotel rooms exactly
so now you're the girl that's quiet
about it somebody else got the shot but
if you're the girl that's taking
pictures or videos without consent while
I'm sleeping
I put them night night
I ain't no UFC fighter either yeah yeah
yeah knock them out yeah one more thing
about Jake why do you think he beats
Conor in boxing because I think the same
thing I'm curious about your reason I
think he's he's good at boxing I think
he's like very good at both good at
boxing and been focused on it for years
Connor hadn't just boxed in years and he
seems a little more content now he got
his proper 12 money oh I don't think
it's that at all I I think it's
literally just he's good at boxing and
he has an immense size Advantage yeah
that's true too kind of fun I think when
he first started UFC at 145. you know
what I mean imagine he knocks out uh
Connor yes
[Music]
like Connor's probably walking around
now at like 175 and he swole as hell
like he's not even in like actual kind
of fighting shape he's gonna be slow at
that weight too does he have any
incentive to fight Jake
I think the fight would be crazy money
yeah yeah if he needs that it is crazy
money and if he thinks that he can
actually beat him I think Conor believes
he could beat anybody on the planet I'd
rather see that fight Than Jake versus
Tyson
take first Tyson yeah yeah it's so
engaging though Tyson anything is going
to be so much fun but I hear you like I
think it makes for a better fight yeah
come on Tyson destroys so unless he's
just running like what um who do you
fight uh Jones yeah like he was just
running the Whole Foods Jones won that
fight
no I didn't I'm pretty sure he was
running the whole thing not between the
wildest [ __ ] he didn't even remember
he didn't say he tweeted it different
thing is different yeah yeah
I don't know I mean I think if I'm
Connor
I'm fighting Jake as soon as I possibly
can because the kid is getting
exponentially better at boxing every
single year so
the earlier you get him the better yeah
what if it's MMA
that's
Connor right even with the size of bench
yeah because like here's the thing I
don't think Connor's Jujitsu is good or
anything like that or is wrestling is
good and like but the kicks are just
different like defending kicks like it's
just a very different thing to be in
there and have to worry about the legs
as well and Connor was a kickboxer like
he's proficient with the kicks so that's
something I just think you can't it's
just it would be an unfair Advantage for
Connor now if they just did a straight
kickboxing fight that would be
interesting as hell but I think what
Conor would do is chew away at that that
uh front leg you know what I mean like
you've seen certain guys do it you just
chew up the front leg you can't even
move you can't punch anything nothing
like you saw uh in that what uh old boy
did the Connor say again isn't that what
old boy did to Connor I think Poirier
Poirier in like the fight in early 2021
he took the leg took the leg took the
leg and then 100
and then Conor went after the leg in
their second fight yeah and uh but yeah
dude it was just like you even saw like
the Izzy Paul Acosta fight you remember
that yeah and Izzy just started chewing
away at that [ __ ] leg and Paul
costume couldn't even move forward yeah
you're just standing there like frozen
yeah so I think that but that is more
competitive yeah like I'm almost that's
better yeah I'm almost not interested in
Jake fighting him just strict boxing
because I think it will be too easy for
Jake is that crazy well it's crazy to
say yeah but Conor's not big
he's still got power with that hook yeah
the left hand is powerful it's great and
he is quick I don't know but how crazy
is it that
Jake boxing was a [ __ ] joke
and now we're going yeah I think he
beats Connor
yeah within six fights yeah I mean
Knockouts even if they're not boxers the
perception uh you have of a human being
when you see them like put another guy
to the [ __ ] mat and they're
unconscious yeah it's just a different
yeah I'm going to look at you
differently every time you do you gotta
respect and not not only outside the
room but like in the room that's another
thing with Connor Connor can't go in
there and play games with him like Conor
could go in there and play games with
Floyd a little bit because he fully
doesn't have that one punch power like
obviously TKO you don't get that one
punch get out of here
son Jake well six five two three you
know five fights three Kos
he didn't KO would be the first time he
got asked her and he got Woodley the
second time he got Nate Robinson I don't
know whose fifth fight is I can't even
think about it I like that he includes
Nate's uh
we call him out on the pot on that one I
think that is so funny